isn't the whole point of being a
feminist though that women are entitled
to have their own views absolutely so
she's perfectly entitled to her views
yeah but you can't you might not like
but I'm here isn't she exercising her
right as a are you a feminist no I am
not really no you know I wouldn't don't
go that time you don't want to be a
feminine no because I think if feminists
really believed in equality but you guys
don't I would love for you there is an
oil rig hiring there is an engineer I
would actually love to see Avis no
seriously seriously uh there is a
building being built next to my building
go do it feminists but go do it in me
when you find the man you want to get
married to are you saying you will
literally you will be with that man
whatever happens the rest of your life
yes for for the vows that we're supposed
to live how do you know you can keep
them I I mean look it I think it's a
choice